[Music]
anybody familiar with
he who is known as russian popeye
russian popeye who has this been
debunked yet
hey olive oil they're fried chicken it's
russian popeye walking around
oh oh this [ __ ] guy you've seen him
right i seen that guy he put synthol in
his
is he biceps
joe rogan or what oil like it's it's
like what girls use i think before they
did the bbl they would do oil
brazilian butt lift
we talk about this here very often so
it's not hard
i don't think so so a man
russian popeye for his artificially
pumped up arms is being urged by fans
to reconsider his dangerous body mods
he's gonna die in five years are they
only doing this because he's russia now
how convenient come on
russian news we left them alone are they
going to deploy that guy
they should he should be sure sure how
to pronounce this i apologize throw him
out on the battlefield make him the
captain of america
carrillo let's go
captain russia wait isn't there an
actual what was his name the dude from
uh scarlett's movie was it captain con
skull red school no
it's not captain comedy there was a dad
it was the opposite of captain america
it was scarlett johansson's uh
quote-unquote father talked about red
skull
no no it's read something though yeah
captain america the opposite of the
olympic gotcha red shield russian guy
kremlin you're sure it's not captain
kami we'll call it i like that better
actually so that sounds like the
opposite anyways this guy the russian
comrade communist okay who goes by the
name rookie bazooky on social media
that's pretty cool it's still sporting
bulging muscles despite having to
undergo life-saving surgery on them two
years ago life-saving what the [ __ ] this
is psa warning do not put olive oil
inside
don't put olive oil hey the rest of this
episode you got to talk about an accent
all right this dude who's 25 years old
became a social media sensation for
videos that show him flexing his giant
biceps or wearing outlandish designer
clothes he's 25 he's 25 why do we allow
this why do we make these guys pop curls
for the girls so he began his synthol
injections in 2017 in an attempt to get
bigger arms duh for curls and girls it
is a product that bodybuilders use to
enhance muscle mass and create larger
bulges but can also cause nerve and
muscle tissue damage
in muscles and even affect
cardiovascular health oh no way dude
it's way position isn't that crazy who
would have thought it doesn't support it
of 85 medium chain triglyceride
oil and 7.5 lidocaine and 7.5 alcohol
vodka and olive oil
doctors have warned mr territion that he
could face amputation or even death
quote unquote i bolt up my arms when i
was 20 due to my own stupidity
oh he regrets it oh uh i'm not good at
this i bulked up my arms when i i'm
terrible
that's so bad it just sounds like you
have cerebral palsy yeah you got it you
got to finish
we'll fix this with an edit hey do it
like you have cerebral palsy
maybe you'll sound russian
there you go all right we fixed it cool
why are you going after them man why are
you going after them that's what he said
i disagree with him but i see that nick
the funny thing is that his words say
due to my own stupidity i did not think
about the consequences and i'm over here
trying to [ __ ] emulate that in
terrible russian
um in 2019 mr tereshin had to undergo
corrective surgery to remove lumps of
hardened petroleum jelly from his arms
quote-unquote petroleum jelly is not
designed for injection only external
application his doctor said at the time
what a lot of karil injected about three
liters into is it irreversible
i mean it looks like he just damaged the
[ __ ] out you know like can you go back
to normal at all i don't think you
should be allowed to after you do some
[ __ ] like that i mean should we see it
again
because if he if he claims he regrets it
why does he just [ __ ] take it out oh
my lordy
can he eat a whole can of spinach
yeah or anything like that
he's got body dysmorphia a little bit
yeah a little a little it's his job bro
oh yeah
i mean doesn't he does he go into the
mirror and go full so it's completely
non-functional yeah well like
there's like silly [ __ ] videos of him
doing stuff like curling and like just
doing it it doesn't like 10 pounds when
you do that it doesn't make you stronger
whatsoever no well the difference is
just because he injects liters of this
[ __ ] in there it doesn't mean he's
stronger it just means it's bigger and
then he's the same strength because it's
not it's not muscle it's just it's just
lipids you know what it is steroids
steroids are different though right yeah
yeah definitely alcohol and [ __ ]
jelly it's like it's filler it's filler
yeah
that's pretty much what it is
he's a 1995 honda civic with a hot
import night sticker on the back of his
bumper which is sick
it says type r
type r that he stole from an integra
that he put back
he didn't change anything about it
still a soccer mom's car i [ __ ]
that's pretty he's probably gonna lose
his arm
which is kind of [ __ ] to say but it's
probably gonna happen he [ __ ] up
already in 2019 when he put three liters
of petroleum jelly in each arm that's so
sad you guys could change anything about
yourself physically what would that be
and you can't have just a giant glorious
golden penis smaller dick honestly it's
such a shut up she's a [ __ ] thing to
lug around should somebody get this guy
out because here's the thing
here's what you don't understand about
having a huge [ __ ] fat [ __ ]
you get hard guess what dude i swear to
god you might get a brain injury or
something
you just pass out oh my god
too much i feel so bad for you it's
horrible let's start a gofundme for
steve
people got to donate blood to them so
you can get hard on
blood that's why i need the same type of
overflow tank like a [ __ ] how cars
have that for coolant
i'm telling you man you know what i have
been working on
my butt cheeks yeah let's see a lot of
squats
we've been squatting yeah hell yeah and
doing uh me and my girlfriend workout
with this trainer they they started
doing this i mean not started hip thrust
yeah yeah get on the ground and you put
like a big ass [ __ ] belt barbell and
you just [ __ ] the air yeah [ __ ] it man
your ass just like
let's see let us see the progress
stand up come on first of all bart's not
here you've known me for a long time do
you remember my my young butt it wasn't
there
i had no butt yeah
this is this is a just a few months and
that's [ __ ] show hey let them know
can you see it let them know let them
know actually
i got a little bit this way this way
[Applause]
that's why i joined this community it's
a great book that's why we like it you
know this is a good ass last remaining
safe
you want me to yeah is that cool all
right this is mutual well if he gets to
i think we should all yeah
not bad right
this [ __ ] right now
oh god damn
why thank you why are you afraid to
touch it
you know this is what i love about you
guys it's the last remaining place on
youtube where men can celebrate being
men
do masculine things like celebrate
masculine body parts and no [ __ ] here
to take us down
today
if we want to be like yo i like your ass
bro
like there's no girls that are being
like hey what about our asses yeah so
can you thought about you okay it's
about canal's butt yeah guess what yeah
okay you're the best assassin
shine on kunal's butt yeah hey thanks
brother
we could regret this later but just
because for the sake of like really
really deep and honest and vulnerable
conversation let's go around answer that
question if you really could change
something about yourself physically what
would it be dude just you [ __ ] white
i'm just kidding
it's very good that's way good i could
really change i would myself
man
i would have
longer
this part
i think this is cool
i think this is cool but this part how
much longer stretch it out a little bit
longer
that much that much more longer yeah
what do you call that like an ankle girl
yeah a girl growth i want to grow the
ankles it's good i think everything else
is pretty nice you get an ankle
extension but then if i go
if i grow the limbs a little longer i
think i'm going to have to grow the
wrist a little bit i'd be weird that'd
be weird because then i don't want to be
like a dude that's like short
like a penguin short top or no like a
like a t-rex you know like it's like
small yeah
that would be pretty nice that has to be
physical
yeah yeah yeah yeah physical you already
picked white though you're white i'm
just kidding it's not all right i'm
using it up already now he wants to
share he's like
come on let's give him the floor guys
men support men here yeah
i mean if it counts i mean i would i
would like to uh take away my uh
autoimmune diseases that cause dry skin
shut up give me some vanity answers no
it's truly vanity because my skin gets
so dry i got all these like little like
dry spots i don't want eczema nobody
notices that's physical no he's being
vulnerable guys it's supportive
and say that he's attractive anyway
thanks for supporting me in my time of
need
well i don't want my dairy allergy i got
a tube but on my scalp dry skin i want
to see longer calves
yeah what do you got anthony you want a
new face
why don't you suggest in your face i
think we all agree a new face would be
good
you know new faces being a fresh start
for you and i want more
a danceable face
a face for dancing
hey how about a first place face how
about that
let's go
and it kind of rhymes too
that's a good start no that's not
physical it's not physical but you're
still in hell new physical friends no
you can't have that you can't have that
you know what's really like hurtful to
do is like suggest stuff for other
people like wouldn't you not like to
have nicer teeth
oh yeah i could see that
that was an issue but damn
it's really good i wish all of you were
dead so what's the answer anything all
right um
i think if i be honest uh i was always
one of those dudes who grew up i was
like oh man i don't like feet i don't
like feet but it's probably because i
was projecting this insecurity you don't
like your own i don't like my own feet
what was wrong with you yeah what's
wrong you got an extra club hobbit feet
you know what i'm saying look can we see
what does that mean though you got like
hairy feet when you're uh you're uh
what's it called the uh the top part the
middle toe
is like longer than like the uh second
toe yeah freaking it's like a name it's
like the
better for dancing it's not it's not
longer it's like the same uh length if
you will is it flipping us off is it
like no it's not flipping you off it's
just the same length as like the next
toe yeah rather than like that's like so
like i like girl hair an interesting
place so i got like hairy feet as well
so it's like it makes me feel all weird
but you're a man yeah you're a man dude
lucky for you i'm you're just asking me
something because i'm trying to tell you
that you're [ __ ] perfect the way you
are you son of a [ __ ]
last chance to change your face
[Laughter]
lock
you know what we'll do a part two and
make sure that he knows that he wanted
this decision most of you are going to
hell
you're 100 sure about the feet sting huh
okay no more face it's been six months
so anthony six months ago let's cut to
what he said okay are you
sure this long island cosmetic surgeon
you you come to me for feet
you're sure
let me say
let me say i never feed my whole [ __ ]
life hey you walk in here with that face
you come here by your feet people are
not going to really see your feet
they're going to see your face
between between me and you guys you see
this [ __ ]
you see this [ __ ]
you got to support each other and then
it never happens wherever you go we got
cracks now you can put cracks over are
you kidding me
i just love that character so much it's
called slippers at 50
there's no being vulnerable here i just
love that [ __ ] character so anthony
for so long that's why i like the
character at the moment look at this
look at the mirror man i'm done today
i'm literally done today
my face is cheaper too huh you got one
of those
[Music]